sur ce plateau jean paul teissonnière
avocat du syndicat des chauffeurs vtc
bonjour merci on vous montre sur ce
plateau avec cet arrêt de la cour de
cassation est ce qu'on peut parler de
jurisprudence est ce que on peut
imaginer une requalification en contrat
de travail pour tous les chauffeurs de
vtc
oui exactement c'est une moment
extrêmement important de l'évolution du
dossier
jusqu'à présent ont considéré que la
jurisprudence n'est pas tout à fait
fixée que il restait quelques marges
d'incertitude
depuis l'arrêt qui vient d'être rendue
la requalification en contrat de travail
est absolument automatique tous les
critères de cette qualification était
examinée par la cour de cassation qui a
répondu d'une façon non équivoque elle
considère que le statut de travailleur
indépendant qui était fait aux
chauffeurs hubert est un statut fictif
c'est la cour de cassation qui le dit
à partir de là bien entendu la
requalification s'impose avec des
conséquences en cascade en terme
d'indemnisation extrêmement important
justement ça peut se chiffrer à combien
je pense que c'est à partir de cent
mille euros qu'on doit pouvoir calculer
les dommages intérêts ce sont des sommes
relativement importante
la convocation en disant que c'est un
travail fictif nous dit également que on
a affaire du travail dissimulé le
travail dissimulé c'est un délit
susceptible de sanctions pénales c'est
également une faute qui entraîne des
dommages intérêts automatique à hauteur
de 6 mois de salaire minimum mais il ya
également les heures supplémentaires a
recalculé il y aller minimum de salaire
le remboursement des frais vous savez
que les chauffeurs ont dû acheter leurs
véhicules automobiles ont dû peut payer
eux mêmes leurs frais de décence et 2 et
toute une série de frais professionnels
qui devait être à la charge de
l'entreprise donc si on fait un calcul
sur plusieurs années ce sont des sommes
pour chacun des salariés hubert ce sont
des sommes tout à fait considérables
auxquels ils peuvent prétendre
et est-ce qu'on peut parler d'une remise
en cause
modèle dubé risation on sait qu'il ya eu
un même type de problème pour über du
côté de la californie de new york
notamment oui oui moi je ne vois pas
comment il ya eu deux deux événements il
ya eu le conseil constitutionnel qui a
dit contrairement au voeu du
gouvernement dans une loi récente qu' on
ne pouvait pas retirer aux juges la
capacité de requalifier le contrat et la
cour de cassation qui a embrayé sur
cette décision et qui a effectivement
requalifier le contrat en contrat de
travail donc maintenant je ne vois pas
comment über pourrait se sortir dans la
situation dans lesquelles elle s'est
mise aujourd'hui la fédération nationale
des auto entrepreneurs la fn à eux
dénoncent elles cet arrêt de la cour de
cassation considère qui va nuire à
l'économie des plateformes pourquoi
certains chauffeurs ne veulent pas du
statut de salarié celui faut là où il
faut leur demander je crois qu'à une
incompréhension
il ne s'agit pas de d'attaquer le statut
d'auto entrepreneur ou de de critiquer
le statut de travailleur indépendant il
s'agit de constater que dans ces
dossiers et dans ces circonstances là
toutes les conditions étaient réunies
pour qu'on requalifier en contrat de
travail
si on si on le ce que ce que reproche la
cour de cassation a eu peur c'est
d'avoir maquillé la vérité c'est d'avoir
transformé la réalité de manière à se
soustraire à un certain nombre
d'obligations
si on respecte le statut de travailleur
indépendant il n'y a pas de difficulté
simplement hubert ne l'a pas respectée
et donc la sanction c'est une
requalification est ce que c'est la fin
du modèle économique du beurre en france
et pour toutes les autres plateformes
est ce que l'avenir de ce type de
plateforme est en danger alors
l'attitude du verre d'où le dira mais la
poursuite du projet d'hubert suppose de
profondes modifications dans ses
relations avec les chauffeurs et il a on
est loin du compte à l'heure actuelle
pour l'instant il ya une requalification
pour tous les contrats en cours et pour
tout le passé et pour l'avenir et
appartient hubert de faire des
propositions qui seront examinées par
les chauffeurs
merci jean paul teissonnière d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes
au cas des syndicats des chauffeurs vtc
merci